why they know that further ado but I am
currently at Facebook the work i'm going
to be talking about today is the work I
was doing right before joining Facebook
so I've only been about six months so
this was some stuff I was doing thing
about back at USC aisi and so we're
taking a slightly different tact and
then the previous work so setting the
context for what I'm going to talk about
here is I've been doing a lot of
thinking about networks for a long time
and more and more I got involved in
networks that actually had a table
aspects with them and some of the work I
was working on was really trying to
understand the communities and how
communities evolve over time and how the
nodes in those communities might change
over time in particular was interested
in trying to protect what I notice
likely to leave a community is becoming
a more peripheral note he said likely to
join another community and I looked at a
lot of the literature and I was not too
happy about some of the formulations
that I had in particularly they seem to
come up with these snapshots of graphs
and they come up with a dog methods and
well how do we create what the snapshot
is and what the ages were and I wasn't
too happy about why because they didn't
seem to really justify some of those
some of those parameters and I want to
understand them a little bit more and so
the word that came out of this is what
I'll be talking about today's think a
little bit about well how you actually
take this input and create these
networks so I said you can create your
social study can find communities and
track them over time those parameters
going into how the network looks at any
given time is going to be very important
and so the work here is much more
data-driven is much more empirical in
terms of let's actually try these
various parameters and see what actually
happens in what in the results you may
find and to give to give you a sense
this comes back to a tube with what the
what Patrick was a little bit earlier
today we need introduced this poll
session the bootay the the way I'm
looking at the world is that yes you
have this over time you see a lot of
noise in your world
they may interact in various ways and so
for example you might at that very time
slot see these various interactions
between knows that may be directed they
may not be directed they may be these
kind of permanent things that are a link
to a page that's come to this permanent
record of a link between the pages well
there may be an email that's a kind of
instantaneous thing it may be a
friendship like what you have in in the
Facebook or friend follow and the
Twitter graph that a little bit more
persistent but even there you still have
people interacting and say they send
messages back and forward they retweet
to each other and so and so forth so how
do you deal with this whole mass of
different things and I wanted to try to
get us a little bit sense a better sense
of how to deal with it so in this
particular case for example the question
is at if you do observe all these
interactions or over time and your time
step 5 and you once they say well I want
to say something about what's going on
at time five what are the communities
what what are the notes like who's the
most central person the question is
about what bacio de Graaff really looked
like at that point and surveys people
have looked at various aspects of doing
it the first one maybe well let's just
take a look at that particular time step
and we can say it's going to be within
the last eight at the last week it
doesn't really matter well yes MOA right
now right so it doesn't really matter
but a lot of people say well let's just
look at the graph as it looks right now
within within this epsilon of team so
this this is the graph I'm going to look
at and see what's going on here and I'm
going to justify whatever I found based
on face on this another one it says
Patrick point out there's also this more
time or a thing of like a sliding window
if you will so let's look at the last
couple of time steps and we're just
going to slide it forward and say well
what happened over the last a couple of
weeks or days what have you and you took
basic going to aggregate everything so
in that particular window and that's
going to be your current state of the
world and so okay so now you have that
parameters well what should that window
be very often a lot of people have paid
pieces if now let's just take a look at
to go back to the 222 whenever we
started collecting data and say this is
all the data we've ever seen this is not
the graph it's basically it's an
aggregator everything be seen so far and
this is this is the state of the world
to be econo we are going to work with
that and we're going to treat things
that happened back at time step one
exactly the same as what is happening in
time step 5 and sometimes that might be
justifiable sometimes me
be not and so the question is that is
one is one answer the right or the wrong
answer I think it really says it depends
on what the question is now I'll talk to
that throughout the talk as well the
final thing you might also think about
as well as do then sometime we can save
all the things that happen right now are
much more important than things that
happened back back in the day in so now
you have some kind of time decay and
you're going to deal with the things
here you're going to wait too much
higher than things that happening in the
past but you're not going to completely
forget about them because they might
still be informative if for whatever
question you might have so now these are
just some of the things you might be
able to do the question of course is
well what should you be doing and why
right yeah right so the thing is that
I've seen all of these types of
occupations in the literature and
everybody does whatever they do and they
don't necessarily is put in context with
other types of aggregations and then
justifiable why it's why is this the
right one and so in particular this kind
of question and all the results you have
yeah they consistent across the
different types of aggregations did you
actually use the right to aggregation
particularly if you don't find the
answer you don't tell you you were
looking for is that was this just
doesn't work and maybe it doesn't happen
to too many of us here because
presumably we are scientists enough that
we want to delve into the question but
if you talk about practitioners or
people new to the field ages would say
well we tried this thing it just didn't
work we don't know why so we'll move on
to something else and so the thing is
important an upon us as well to say when
we actually do in contempo aggregation
to justify it a little as to what these
were the options but this is what we
chose for whatever reason I think as it
can be important all right partly
particularly because it has such a
traumatic effect on any time stream
analytics so the question I wanted to
talk about here it really touched the
segregation in effect whatever analytics
you have HAP downstream and particular
for the questions that that I that was
kind of driving this is at any given
time what would the network look like
and I'm going to justify why I wanted to
look at that later on right the question
is really well how to the communities
then what do they look like at any given
time what did they look at following
some hard to the
evolved and how can we track them things
how do they know change within a within
a network are they becoming more than
central are they likely to leave a
particular community and also on all
sorts of all types of the impacts and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
some machinery experiments at the end
and say well depending on how aggregate
it's also going to have an impact there
clearly so stepping pack is first the
first question is for how do we then
generate a network for a particular time
T and so as summation already there's
the question of what is the current
network and so at any given time T it's
if you can think about email for example
at any given time T plus minus epsilon
chance to second when you're going to
see maybe one message or a couple of
emails if you go up into the global
world to the if there's someone is small
enough chances are you're going to going
to see a small and message even on
things on Facebook scale right so one of
the things that you might want to to to
to sales as well as first to come up
with a time window which say this is
really my time frame is going to be one
day it's going to be a minute gonna be
five minutes depending on what you want
to do so that's one parameter you might
want to think about with respect to how
you can start a quick equity the other
thing is I mentioned also passages
clearly may have some its or some impact
and they are informative and so we so
you might not also want to only consider
the current window you also want to
consider pass in windows questions will
help you deal with that right so in this
case you might want to introduce this
decay parameter alpha same old in past
in the past history this is how much I'm
going to deal with it and ask Julia or
recursive function then and the other
thing is you might want to do is at some
point maybe that weight just falls way
way below 2020 to a such a low weight
that you just want to prune it out
because it is going to have some
computational impact on large graphs you
really do not want to attend two times a
graph so many of the kind of things that
we might want to like label propagation
other things like that so three
parameters so I I thought about it I
thought these were the three parameters
that kind of made sense to me at least
thinking about the space of aggregating
these these kind of just kind of data
and so once the once we have
we can anything about want you to
network look like right inside what I
defines they say I have the occasion C
matrix at any given time step with with
respect to the my window I'm going to
then going to say okay let's take that
and then we're going to add any occasion
C matrix for from the prior window as
well and that takes it going to be my
occasions you matric matrix at any given
time I'm not ruining anything here
because I want to keep even low wages
across across time but for the final
graph I'm going to look at I'm basically
going to do the pooling down here in
sable and for the graph I'm actually
going to look at for particular given
times that I'm going to prove out
promote low a Twitter Lloyd wait ages so
that's basically what I wanted to do and
one of the things is you can also just
to choose to just realizing get rid of
the time window we can just normalize it
to say well it's just an integer of
constant you can just normalize time so
now that I know have a sense of what the
network should look like any given time
the question then is ok that's good so
let's figure out what are the
communities where the north of the how
do they interact right and so in this
case here I was not I was someone
agnostic answering in terms of what
should the clustering I could look like
and so on and so forth because i was
with much more interested in the table
aggregation so in this case yeah just
used to stay on popularity clustering
algorithm to identify my communities any
given time and so you can use both
waited on where you're dead yes I used
way to the edges in this case here but
any resource of showcase obviously going
to be the same other use weighted arm
waited so you come up with that set of
communities the question is well how do
they then track them right what we want
to do is we want to identify communities
that are in the in the previous
community in the previous time step as
well and so in this case here I did not
spend too much time thinking about that
either because people in the literature
have look at this and that was not
really that the main focus of water
wants to look at here so I'm basically
going again here where people have so
much heuristics people come up with in
terms of saying it's like is this the
same communities and a previous time
step so in this case you can think a
community continues if the majority of a
community
move saw on so that if the majority of
the community moves forward and if in
more than half of the current community
is from a previous community and more
than two-thirds of that previous
community move forward these eight
continues you can also think about what
emerges and say about these are the two
communities that kind of merged in so
now we have a community where the
significant portions up two of two or
more other communities from the previous
time step so now here we say this would
be a merge step that these communities
merged together some other community you
can think about the same thing about
splitting our community splits in this
case here said that at least thirty
percent of a community easy to split off
and form another community and if you
have two of those aspects that that come
you need split otherwise we've easily
just said it died at that point so now
we have an idea about talking about
communities that they continue emerge
split and so on 44 notes is basically a
straight forward to aspect there once we
know the community we know what i know'd
it more is leaving or staying in a
community of over time steps and in this
particular aspect if a community splits
or dies I peasley said that they or they
noted something other and form of the
machinery aspects later on I based
ignore that so there's been a harsh our
communities and nodes now I wanted to
get into that experimental studies about
not that we know this as we start to
think about aggregating the data how do
how are these things effective and so
the experimental study here is really a
took some real data and I very my
parameters I looked at the communities
that they were formed how well they how
long they lift and so on and so forth
and try to see well how to add the very
impairments actually change what we see
here right and I also applied machinery
so the data says I used heroes will be
small England at acceptable so I
mentioned a little bit earlier and also
the world trade flows data which please
see represents how much Suge countries
traded with one another in a given year
so the email the n one data set is
basically continuous in terms of we have
the emails we have the time sent for the
emails for the world trade flows data we
only have it on a per year basis but we
do have it over multiple years from 1960
put two
from 2000 and so this is over two years
of data for the Enron data set and I
basically decided to focus on on the 50k
and pruning step so I basis at this time
window for this particular study here to
just be one window just to put on even
footing with the Wall Street flows and
say well let's just fix the time window
and look and look at the other aspects
so varying parameters I basically are
very empowerment of the DK from alpha
from going to point 5 all the way up to
12.5 is I only take care I we think
about take half of the way from the
previous time step in to carry forward
up to one where I take the full weight
basically completely aggregating it
putting steps I had because of the
weights are the two different networks
for different so I also use different
pruning and so I different putting steps
for 444 for each of these two as well
right and so without further routed
going into some of the statistics there
so some of the things I found so just to
show you how to romantic things really
be Leo I mean they are really dramatic
so in this case is this is what fairy
flow in 1993 so this is after about 30
years of trades so if I had no a
services that offer to one so obviously
aggregate all the data you have a really
nice super dense network if I set it to
point 5 and also had a relatively high
era you basically say here that is
basically completely almost all
Singleton's with a few strong
communities for peopie enlarge it
completed that generates down to 22 to
almost nothing huge effect huge impact
clearly things we did by how much is
yeah so I think yeah so the edge wait
here for for the country's IVC said I
basically normalized five vertical a
year and say well what is what is the
ratio or whether it's a fraction of a
trade between people between the
different rate so that's going to be the
weight so ninety percent of my trades
with you in
I'm sorry value yeah absolutely yes your
thresholds unaided yes so the same thing
is we're somewhat similar to consider a
different how good question no no I so I
think it's going to have a definite but
i think that i think the deltas and the
alphas are more correlated and the a
less necessary because this is these are
purely for pruning just getting rid of
low weights right so the outfit
basically how much decay you have so
there is so clearly so if i have alpha
of one it basically saying saying my
time in window to infinite right so they
are really in that sense absolutely so
giving you some sense of what actually
happens as well just to look at the kind
of Master comes out so if you look at
the Volturi force or n run for 5 4.5 and
a small error for for for for for the
world trade shows and I think the error
was very different for Enron but still
watch but what you see here is that
every single rose this is one year or
one time step I guess I bellini to to
move one time step but basically you can
see is a huge issue huge mess right it
gets it very very very very chaotic wear
the collar coat so whether you die or
whether you soo ey whether you whether
it's a birth or death whether you split
over they emerge it's all over the place
if you move into here you can see based
in terms of milk moving all over the
place as well I mean this is P pretty
chaotic but we can clean up for looking
at just communities and look at what
what community structures look like high
alpha you get a lot of stability though
well for things get much more chaotic
you see you same thing on the undie on
the n1 as well high alpha you get a lot
of stability though alpha again things
get very chaotic the interesting thing
though it happens is that if you start
locking things like community sizes
regardless of what what what those
paramedics are you see you see some
interesting you see something
interesting trends and particularly here
in the and the this is Enron idly
where you see some pretty consistent
change in terms of how big the
communities actually are if you squint
just the right way so it turns out that
some of the strong communities do seem
to be at least at the right size
although deity the internals of those
communities might look very very
different also in terms of looking at
how long these community actually last
again what happens is that if you
interface look at a infinite time window
in in one data set you see some some
very very strong grouping that actually
makes a lot of sense and these basically
came up from from basically from year
one and lasted toward the whole area
what happens is if you go into a high
floor alpha you see the same groupings
but they don't know don't ask quite as
long you have you have a subset of that
group one over here group 2 over here
forgot to a tool to align them it's a
subset but they still lasts for
basically 38 years over here for group
to not only there's a 31 years but still
you have a lot of the core group 3 only
lasted 22 years only a small part of it
and all the other groups basically only
less if you want one or two years when
we came over here lot of other groups
lasted 400 for a decade or more over
over there's a huge effect right same
thing is you look at the things like
centrality in the world trade flow so
one of the things if you have a very low
alpha the just the most mark and just to
point it out here at the form of West
Germany basically disappears and Germany
comes up when we when the Berlin Wall
fall now what happens over here is what
happens if you have a smaller even a
slight Lisa relatively high alpha what
happens is that the former West Germany
hangs around for a while but and the new
Jimmy takes a long time so to kind of
rise and so you have an interesting
phase shift there so now what we happen
is that we have the two large entity
longevity of communities versus looking
at some of these phase shifts and
sometimes you actually need to explore
multiple values of these attributes to
actually get into that and I think I'm
almost out of time so so so I'm doing ok
I think I ought to speed through this so
for the machine learning aspect just to
see about some of the other networks
that are being impacted on this here you
can look at these classification
problems either for the community so for
the notes
the community's split merge or
continuously with a note did it leave a
stay the attributes here are basically
flat knitted it out and the proposition
rising is I'm coming up with a whole
bunch of various attributes on
communities and notes in terms of the
structural basis or structural can
attribute because that's really all i
care about here the basic standard
machine running a paradigms in terms of
to engage cross validations and so on
and so forth i'm not going to go into
the interesting things here as you can
elude we can assign in the other grass
as we change halfan ada you can
basically see here in terms of for
example continuing continuing
communities grows as alpha gross but
they also the decay as be as i say that
the case because we start putting more
same thing with the n1 what you see is
really really interesting for the for
the footnotes you basically at some
point things we basically become
completely to generate at all that you
bet I have nothing going on there it's
not the nothing for these are the
community sorry for communities there's
like no mo chuisle splits over here
everything gets a kind of degenerates at
the big streams so what the effects are
non machine learning is that you
basically see at the extreme points
things don't quite work you see here at
the at the at the hyatt us when you
prune a lot because things become a
little bit more stable you can in fact
cleaner level from that from a machinery
just say well just predict the majority
class in some sense very strong cases
again here you see in terms of class or
evolution again here are things that
they generate enough so i was actually
kind of surprised to see this i was
expecting something else but i can you
see here there's an interesting medium
where things of interesting but pretty
stable enough that that it actually does
pretty well so i think i'm all the other
sign but i just want to leave this with
some of the things that i wanted to to
to to kind of highlight they have any
way to pre-process dynamic data i
thought one way to kind of thing about
the pre proceeds pre-processing a
framework to just think a little bit
about it depending on the parents you
choose you can see different structures
come out and so you should explore in
fact if
different parameters are think to
identify this different questions are
going to be a explore in terms of
longevity of strong power source vs.
these fascia study that we saw and
whatever you do I think if you do
actually do a temple aggregation make
sure you justify what you're doing it
and making sure you did the right a
gregarious actually being able to answer
the questions you might have about the
data so leave it at that thanks